- (music playing)
♪Yeah. ♪
♪okay its tea, with GaryVee ♪
♪sipping in the tea ♪
♪i know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting that under my sheet for free ♪
♪ This is tea, with GaryVee ♪
♪ Michael make a play ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- April 8th tea with GaryVee Friday.
Hope everybody's super well,
let's get right into it.
Dustin, I'm ready to go.
- What's up Gary?
- It's good flawless.
- How you doing man?
- Super well.
- Man, it's an honor
to talk to you brother.
- Thank you my man.
- Absolutely.
So what I wanted to talk to you about,
was a little bit about the future of music
and gaming being one in the same.
And I've been noticing a lot of changes
in the way the industry has been moving.
I seen that recently, Travis Scott
just did a live concert on fortnight,
put out a show with Kate Cuddy, next day
the song's, number one.
So I'm starting to see
the shift in the way that
artists are not only promoting their music
but the platforms that they are using.
How do you feel bout the way that,
that's elevating?
- Travis and his people are fucking smart.
Like this has always been the game.
The reason, I mean not the reason,
but like the biggest reason
that Michael Jackson,
Prince, Madonna are on
the pedestals they are
in the music world is because of MTV.
Not just because they
were talented as fuck.
And so what Travis is doing is,
the best artists in the
world always understand
attention, right?
And so wherever there's the attention
is where people go.
And Travis just understands
that, if he goes
and throws a virtual concert on fortnight,
he's going to have millions
of eyeballs, right?
It's the reason, big shout out right now
to the Twitch fan, right?
Like I'm streaming on Twitch right now
and it's going crazy, because that's where
the attention is.
And the attention is on
Ticktock, and believe it or not,
the attention's on LinkedIn and
the attention is on Spotify.
Like this is one big fucking game,
of go to where the attention is.
And if tomorrow, jugajuga
comes out, the app,
like every artist and every entrepreneur,
needs to go there because if that becomes
the attention graph,
and when it goes away,
people was like GaryVee
that's what you said
about Vine, and I'm like, yeah,
fucking (mumbles) put in work on Vine.
So, King Batch made his career on by Vine,
like yes, that's exactly right.
Some shows on TV have three seasons,
when it's the hottest
thing and some things
are Saturday in your life.
And whether it's three
years, three months,
or 16 years, I don't give a fuck how long
the platform's hot.
But yes, if video games are culture now.
Like video games are now
like sports, are now like
music are now like movies.
It's forever now.
Forever, forever.
And so for the rest of your life,
video games will matter and grow
and six year olds now dream
to be professional gamers.
It's the reason I dropped seven figures
on a piece of the fucking call of duty
in Minnesota rocker team.
Like it's here period of story.
And every single artist in the world,
should be screaming on Twitch.
Every single artist in
the world, should be
streaming on Twitch and
should be on YouTube games
and should be fucking goat
mixer and should be going at it.
I think it's crazy to see
where we're going as a world.
I mean, so many young
kids aspire to be Twitch,
streamers and gamers and artists.
I'm interested to know where the doctors
are going to come from
in the future because
everybody's,
- Don't, don't sleep on humans.
We adjust, don't sleep on humans.
We adjust like this.
This amount of video game play is not
going to hurt anybody.
Like, it will hurt a point 001% like,
our thumbs will be fine or they won't.
But guess what?
We slouch cause we sit too much.
Like you can't even imagine
how fucked up you are
from sitting.
- Yeah I know.
- You know what I mean?
What are we going to ban sitting?
I promise you sitting fucks up people
more for the doctor than video games.
And so we need to be more
thoughtful about that shit.
- No, absolutely, absolutely.
It's definitely changing, man.
I think, the way that the
video games are being,
in the culture, the way
that dominate it so much,
it's really forcing
other industries to use
video games as platforms.
I mean, it's almost like
the new distributor.
- No, it's been, it's been.
When Justin TB switched to Twitch,
I remember having those
conversations with those guys
and they are like, this
is going to fucking win.
Videos, it's been.
Because my generation,
now kind of is emerging
to rule the world.
This is what happens,
eventually a generation
becomes the 40 50 60 70 year olds.
Why do you think fucking
everyone's so casual
as a business man and woman dressing now?
Cause we grew up in hip
hop, emerging culture.
We grew up in grunge, we
grew up in not giving a fuck.
And so like, that becomes
the establishment.
- Absolutely.
- Just like just like all
these incredible trends
from trans-gen and fucking alternative,
like men's makeup, that's
going to be the fucking jam
in 25 years when those kids run shit.
- Yeah it's true, it's true.
- And so because we run shit and we're the
Nintendo and Atari generation, it fucking,
it's how it works.
- Yeah.
I'm definitely late to the party then,
because I'm noticing it
now and I'm seeing the
(crosstalk drowns out the conversation)
- And early.
People, everybody here
who's watching right now
feels late to the party on
Ticktock, if they haven't
jumped because I've
been screaming about it
for 18 months and if they
jump right this second today,
theY'll be fucking early.
- Yeah, I jumped a few weeks
ago and I'm building it
tremendously.
I mean it's a great platform for sure.
- How many followers you got?
- I got about 35, 40,000 in
a matter of like two weeks.
- In a second, in a second.
How many times a day are you posting?
- Once or twice a day, I'm trying to get
one or two Ticktocks in a day.
More?
- More.
- Wow. I'm I just, back to,
watch what I do.
I'm about to go to five a day.
Literally last night, at like midnight,
typed my team, and said
we're going to five.
- As an artist, right,
who's always constantly
promoting music, promoting
product, promoting merchandise,
do you think there's
ever too much posting?
Do you think there's too
much of the promoting
of the product or you think
it's go time all the time?
- No, no.
I think there's not too much posting,
but I think four out of
those five need to be
valuable for them.
- And then one that kind
of promotes to them.
- I wrote a book in 2011
called jab jab jab right hook,
and it was about, jabs
are given to the audience.
I see you flip fuck you too.
Jabs are give, give, give, and then
the fifth one is ask.
So I think too many
people promote too much.
If you look at my Instagram, it's like
give, give, give, give, and then it's like
you're going to subscribe to my Twitch.
Give, give, give, give,
give, give, give, give, give,
subscribe to my podcast.
Give, give, give, give, give, give,
sign up for Winetext.
So you got to get your
balance rates like a fighter.
If you're throwing a right
hook, every fucking punch,
I'm going to duck.
- Okay.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- Because the artists
like me who's independent,
I've been independent since 2010.
Am from Providence Rhode
Island, the smallest state
in the country, I packed
all my shit in 2010,
moved to Atlanta Georgia
with no plan but HD camera
and made it happen.
- You know where you had to be.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And it's been so hard ever
since and doing my thing
and I appreciate the advice man, for real.
- You will go to the next level, if you go
fast to the new shit.
How long have you been following me?
- A couple of years.
- You should have been on
ticktock 18 months ago.
- I know.
- Don't fucking make
that same mistake next,
cause in 36 months I'm
going to say something
and I'm telling you right
to your fucking face,
I'm going to be right,
jump the fucking in.
Am in, am in.
Am following you brother.
- Take care.
- Thank you, love.
- Bye.
Big shout out to Rhode Island.
Dustin, what's good?
- What's up?
- How are we seeing, how are
we feeling with the numbers?
Give me the updated numbers.
- It's not looking too great on Twitch.
Okay, well nobody talks anymore.
- Not on Twitch at least.
Well, so we tried changing
some things up today,
just to kind of experiment as far as,
cause yesterday we were on the talk shows
or not yesterday, the
other day, talk shows
and podcasts category,
we changed it today to
just chatting to see what would happen.
- Let me ask you a question,
who the fuck made that decision
after it completely
crushed on the first day.
Who in their right mind decided,
"Hey, let's fuck with something
"that was fucking remarkable."
Help me on this one Dustin.
Was it Tyler, was it you?
- It was both of us, so
- So you and Tyler
joined forces and created
the fucking shit duo,
to fuck me up on Twitch.
- Wait, wait, wait.
So I'm reading the comments on Twitch
and someone said, "Hey,
you should try using
"the just chatting category instead
"because it's just a bigger category.
"And then people who would
be fans of Gary might
"catch it like out of, I guess
"if they're not following you"
So I'm like, okay.
So I threw that suggestion out to Tyler,
he was like, all right, let's try it
and see what happens, and then
we can go back and forth and show
- And I respect, I
respect, I respect your,
Trying to be more like GaryVee.
- Listen, I like it, I like
trying new shit, but I think
I don't like trying new
shit on the second time
after the first time when fucking bananas.
Trying new shit is after you've hit,
Yeah. Let me, explain it,
this is actually going to
help people.
Trying new shit needs to
happen when you've plateaued.
We didn't plateau, we fucking had one day.
- True, true, true.
Noted for the future.
- Let's keep it going.
Big shout out to Facebook,
Twitter, YouTube.
Hi guys.
- Hi Gary.
- Hi.
How are you?
I'm good, I'm Sham,
I'm the editor in chief
and co-founder of average socialite.
And I'm Gurleen, I'm also
an editor here in New York
for average socialite.
- It's very nice to meet you ladies.
- You too
So I was a lawyer for 20
years and about five years ago
I co-founded average
socialite, with my co-founder
CJ in LA, and almost a year ago exactly,
I left law completely to
focus on average socialite.
So now fast forward to today,
we're all in quarantine,
and average socialite is
a website that focuses on,
unique and exclusive
events across the country,
with a focus in LA, New York and DC.
So we're all in quarantine
now and all of the
big events that we usually
cover like Coachella,
music awards shows and movie premieres,
they've all obviously been canceled.
So we were left with,
where does that leave us?
And a CJ, my co founder is actually a
pediatric nurse practitioner,
so it was her idea
to kind of bring, with all
the traffic that we get
through our website to try
to bring some information
and useful things during
Corona virus to our audience.
And more specifically, we
decided to start a page,
that gives advice and information
for a healthcare workers
and people on the front lines.
Like information about where
they can get medical supplies
and transportation and
housing and all these things
that all of these wonderful
companies are offering people
like free meals during their
shifts and things like that.
So we've had a tremendous
response to that,
we built a really strong relationship
with the healthcare community now,
and with all of these
brands that are supporting,
healthcare and we've even reached out to
a lot of our contacts and
they are now also offering
discounts or freebies
for healthcare workers.
My question to you is,
cause you wear so many
different hats, you do
media, you do sports,
you have your podcast and wine.
People will come to you
for one reason or another,
how do you get from the
crossover to other content?
Because eventually, things
are going to hopefully
go back to normal and
we'll start covering events
and going back to our original purpose.
But we don't want to lose
that relationship and we want
to keep adding value to those people,
the new audience that we have.
- There's a couple of things you could do.
One, you should immediately mix in some of
your normal content into it, just to see
how this new audience responds to it,
because people are multidimensional.
Many of the people that are coming over
for this, also enjoy the
things that you cover
day to day, and I think
obviously you're not going to
cover it from a event
standpoint, but there are
all these socialites, are living it out,
on social media and there's
absolutely things to cover
and conversation around.
And there's all sorts of
people, like still dating
in the shadows and things.
There's all sorts of things you can cover,
so I think there's that.
And then number two, if it
becomes meaningful enough,
you basically do a push when
things get back to normal
and you do a hard right
hook like to the prior thing
and say, look, we're starting
this Instagram account
for all the people that came for this
and you literally create it.
I have me the human,
but I'm the orchestrator
of setting something to
Winetext or to Vaynersports
or to the Sasha group.
And what can end up
happening is, you as humans
can do that from, and I assume
the account may be smaller
or may not be, I don't know, but obviously
the base might be there,
but more importantly,
you definitely, if you're doing this all
on average socialite, need
to do a hardcore for a week.
Now we're going to push
you all to this other place
that we're here during this time for that,
and then reset and then
have your small little group
on this new thing you've
created and see if that becomes
a fruitful venture for you
to continue to build on.
- Right, yeah.
And halfway through we
kind of thought about it
and we added like a link
for people to sign up
for our newsletter to subscribe.
So now we've collected like
thousands of email addresses
so that we can reach
out back to those people
that might've believed them.
- Correct.
That's it.
You just have to make that hard pivot
and probably be fine with it.
- Cool.
Last night I posted, am
posting out content right now
on Instagram that I
know will underperform,
but I wanted to do the
thing that I wanted to do.
And I think a lot of people struggle with
posting something they know
will underperform in likes,
but it's still on strategy.
So a lot of times in this
scenario, they won't want to
do those, like, hey like
just basic sign up for that,
like switch over, follow this.
They know it won't do as
well, but that's actually
what you need to happen.
And so doing the right
thing for business strategy,
versus what's right for
the algorithm, is something
a lot of people who are
watching this need to learn.
- Yeah, we're just
concerned because we want
to make sure that they
engagement is always there
for the audience
- And that's the problem,
and cause I totally get it.
But the engagement can go
down if it's over on strategy
to separate the audiences
based on your situation.
I would be comfortable with five posts,
than have 10 posts, be
very strong call to actions
to sign up for this new
account, knowing that
they would get a fourth of the likes
that you're accustomed to,
but you're going to siphon
the people over, and that
is the actual punchline.
People care about their
aesthetic too much,
you can fucking archive it.
People also don't give a
fuck about your aesthetic.
Like it's all, feed.
Like so, there's a lot of,
you see where I'm going?
- Sure.
There's a lot of things people overthink
and we let illusions become
the thing we decide on
instead of the reality of
smart business practices.
- Right.
- Awesome.
- And thank you so much.
Bye.
- Take care ladies, bye, bye.
- Yep.
- So reading the comments
again, they said actually
a Twitch decides who
goes on the front page,
so the category didn't matter.
- Of course.
- I don't know. I don't know anything.
- I knew that part.
- I don't know anything.
- Clearly, lets keep going.
- Hi
- Felipe, how are you?
Pleasure to meet you.
- Pleasure to meet you,
man, love the bucket hut.
- Thank you so much.
- Looks good.
- My question for you today is about
communications and truth.
I like to tell a quick
story that leads me into it.
I was second generation
immigrants from Chile to Norway.
Grew up there, very dense
environments, lots of caring
about other people's opinions,
I moved out at a young age,
to create distance.
So I've had the pleasure and
freedom to do what I want
for nine years now, tested a lot of shit.
And I've come to a place
in my life where I want
to take my work ethic
serious, I want to taste
my sense of discipline
and I want to get serious
about my personal brands.
And you inspire me just
by the way that you talk.
So my question to you
today, is what skills
do I have to master to
be able to communicate
as truthfully as you,
but that's the same time,
as kindly, empathetically
and compassionately as you.
- Well it's extremely
flattering my friend, thank you.
I think self-confidence.
I just really, you need to,
and I think the way you go there brother,
I think you need to, this
is really interesting answer
and first of all, you
articulate super well,
so I think you've got a real shot.
- Thank you.
- I think some people
just have a natural knack
to communicate.
Felipe I think the thing that
you need to think about is
being comfortable with your shortcomings.
And I think a part that
people don't see enough of me,
in me and don't use it
enough are things like,
me talking about being
an atrocious student,
me not being a great
athlete, me struggling,
like me not having fun in my twenties,
me not having the financial means since
the family doesn't risk my families,
to have to start over.
Like it's the humility
and kind of exposing,
I think the way you can be
empathetic and compassionate,
and look, there's human
traits, some people
are just born with that.
However, I have noticed that
I genuinely believe that
people that share their shortcomings are
so much better, happier and
capable to navigate the world.
And so I think the biggest
thing that probably
will open you up to
that, is actually sharing
With the world, what you suck at.
It's why I bring up eight miles so often.
Right? That last scene, I
bring it up all the time.
Yeah. So I saw the
movie, the day came out,
I mean I was at (mumbles) height,
and that last scene
struck me in perpetuity.
Because I understood what he was doing,
which was if I shit on
myself, you have no leverage.
- I understand that.
- And then once nobody has
leveraged you get happy
and once you get happy
you can share happiness,
compassion, and kindness.
So I think that's the answer.
I also stay in my lane.
One thing that I am very proud
of is I talk about business
and I talk about human
characteristics that
come natural to me.
I don't talk about
healthcare, I don't talk about
geopolitical, I don't talk about
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency,
I don't talk about,
like I don't talk about
shit I don't know.
Like people are like, you come off cocky,
I'm like, I come off
confident cause I talk about
shit I don't know.
- Yeah.
- I think I resonate to that.
I've been posting content
for about five years now,
but it's been on and off.
It hasn't been consecutively,
and I feel like
the way that I communicate
has like created a little,
like a hard shell around the
way that I speak to others.
And it's like kind of defending something
that I built up in an early, young age,
when I first moved out, read
a lot of self help books
and like kind of taught myself how to
like myself in a way, right?
- Of course you did.
- Yeah, and I wanted to talk about that.
But it was like with an
edge, you understand?
- With a chip, with anger.
- Yeah.
- I totally get it.
And listen, I'm a chip too.
Like I went through a school system,
like especially high
school like, there was an
underlining beliefs that
like from the system,
the school system, even
some of my friends parents
that because I was bad at
school, I couldn't win.
And that's rose me, that
drives me, because I was
so woke and thoughtful and understood
the system was broke for me.
And I see that at a
million different places.
I think you need to
articulate that anger, I think
you need to make a piece of content where
you're crying about what
your mom and dad did
or who whatever.
I think that will take a
lot of heat out of the tone.
To your point, I think
that, see I'm not angry
and so I might be a little Jersey street.
I'm competitive, I have conviction,
but I think your question,
and by talking here,
you helped me give you a better answer.
I think the difference
you're seeing in me and you
is I don't have anger.
Yeah.
And I think the way you get that anger out
is by exposing that shadow.
- That makes total sense.
I have tried.
- You've tried putting it out and flat out
saying the truth of the world?
- I feel like that's the only thing I do.
- So you've told everybody
that, and you still,
it didn't work for you?
- I feel like I got the
truth part in, I don't feel
like I have the compassionate,
empathetic, kindly part in.
- Look, there's some real
truth to like, listen,
but you also have like great hair, right?
- Thanks.
And an epic smile, right?
So like, there is a little
bit to the DNA game.
Like, it's not like in seventh,
when I was seven or nine,
my mom was like be kind, she
was a guidance of kindness,
but it was in me, it's
not like I've read a book
at 18 that said kindness
is the online, like, Oh!
There is a little bit of a DNA game,
- But isn't that in all of us, in a way?
- Yeah, but then our
circumstances take over.
Like first we start with
DNA points and then there's
moldability of our
environment and our parenting
and our circumstances.
So, that's why everyone's so quite unique.
But I think recognizing
it, even this conversation
gives me so much uncomfortable optimism
because there's a self awareness that
you're deploying here that
many people just don't.
There are so many people
I know that are just
uncomfortably delusional
and the only person
they're tricking is themselves.
People see through it and so,
- I felt myself being
in that box sometimes.
- That makes sense.
That was your subconscious
and the fact that
it's now in your conscious, means that
now you're in practice mode.
Like these muscles are a lot better
than they used to be,
but they're not as good
as they would have
been, if I started at 18
instead of 38.
- Yeah.
- You're so young, you
just might be in a very
early part of the, of the journey.
- I'm being impatient,
I'm going to give myself
more time to grow.
- Which is amazing
because most times people
are impatient for like
a thing to like flex,
which is like a poison, a car, or a hoodie
or like a vacation or new home.
You're being impatient for your ambition
to a kinder, happier place.
That's fucking, I have
admiration for that.
- Thank you
- I have admiration for you.
- What I don't want you
to do is beat yourself up,
to yourself about being a bad guy.
The best way to be empathetic is to be
empathetic to yourself first.
- Thank you.
- This is absolutely amazing.
- You know what it is?
- Yeah, I hundred percent do.
- I think I have a ton of shortcomings,
but my ability to not judge
myself starts the process
of me being kind to others.
The reason people are
struggling so much out here
and everyone's so upset is because we are
in the golden era of judgment.
Everybody's got a hot take on everybody
- And share their opinion.
- Correct.
And so, unfortunately
social media exposes people.
Nobody's been changed by
Twitter, or Twitch, or Instagram,
everyone's been exposed,
and so, the reason
people are struggling
with judgment from others,
hate or things of that nature, is because
they themselves are judging.
- That makes sense.
- And so, I think that
there's a lot there.
Start with yourself.
Like don't beat yourself up.
Like what did we all do?
We're the output of our
circumstances, and then
this is how I got myself
to 400 trillion to one.
Like you could be upset
about, who you are,
you're not tall enough,
you're not pretty enough,
you're not smart enough,
you're not good enough.
But just even realizing
the likelihood of becoming
a humanist, 400 trillion to
one, you know that whole like,
you're a miracle, like cliche
that like a grandma would say,
is like unbelievably true.
Like, like you get hit
by lightning six times
and win a lotto four times
and still that's more common
than fucking being alive.
And then once you kind
of go there, once you sit
in that stool for a
year, then you're like,
fuck it, let's go.
Like fuck it, like no matter
what my shortcoming is
and there's so many, and
then look for inspiration
from others.
You see so many people that are disabled,
chronically ill and are optimistic.
And then you see people
have nothing but blessings,
and we'll always find
something that's wrong
because that was their DNA,
and that was their parenting,
hat was what their environment.
And if you're a complainer
and you're watching right now,
you need to change your circle.
You need to start hanging out with people
that smoke your bullshit out.
You need to become accountable.
Like, people that complain, think that
other people control shit and there's
unbelievable injustice in the world.
I mean, there's crazy shit, racism,
like religious persecution, sexism.
But the reality is, is
like you're take it,
like take that, knowing that and take
your own control and like move out of
the country You don't like anymore,
just divorce the spouse
you don't like any more,
like quit the job you don't like anymore.
Humility, kindness, empathy, patience,
these ingredients together
leads to happiness.
- Yeah, that makes complete
sense to me and I feel like
I have created an image of my optimism.
I feel like the shell that I've made is
to protect me from negativity.
- I totally understand.
What you need to do what you need to do,
is create a world where
you can easily take it in
and reform it, you know?
- Yeah.
That makes total sense.
- To me, I'm not trying
to protect myself from it.
I've created a machine that takes it
and regurgitates out flowers.
Got it?
- I love that.
- That's why my shit's sustainable.
I'm not trying to run away from it
because it exists a
scale, I've learned how to
take it and reform it
and pop it out different.
It's why I talk about being compassionate
and kind in the face of anger.
It's why I talk about
empathy, when somebody says,
you suck, you're a charlatan,
you're a snake oil salesman,
you're not good, you're overrated.
I go into, man, could you
imagine living a life where
you're pushing people
down on the internet?
Wow, that's some pain.
Not, "Oh, I'm sad, maybe I am".
I don't fucking believe you.
But it also means that all believe you
when people tell me you're the goal.
See, once you don't believe them,
you have to not believe that both ways.
Too many people don't
believe they're haters,
but love their compliments.
People's need for compliments here,
is why they're so hurting.
It's why so many attractive
people, are in such
insecure places.
They're so accustomed to
that positive reinforcement
that when they don't get it any other way,
they crumble because
their self worth, is from
the feedback of the
positive reinforcement.
When that converts to negative
reinforcement, they fold.
I'm thankful for this
parenting circumstance.
Look, I'm not saying I'm special.
This is just how it happened.
Am the reverse, it's why peer
pressure didn't exist for me
in high school.
I'm the reverse, I don't
hear you when you say
I'm a dick, and I don't
hear you, when you say
I'm the goal
And so like it works,
- Because you have your own self worth
establishing yourself.
You shed your own light on it.
- I'm in a cocoon bro.
I'm in a cocoon.
- What's your best advice
to be able to achieve that?
To be in your own head.
- Recognizing it's, it's a possibility.
- Knowing it's possible.
- Knowing it's possible
is a great starting point.
And then, practice, practice
like truly going against
your own intuitions and
self muscle memories
when somebody's mean to you,
instead of going back at them.
Just like gripping it out and saying,
I feel bad, I'm sorry.
like doing shit that's uncomfortable
until it becomes comfortable.
- That makes sense to me.
- And so I just think that there's,
it's practical positivity, right?
It's like why not choose
happiness and positivity,
but not at the cost of delusion.
You can't be with your homies and be like,
everything's going to be
okay and sitting around
and doing nothing.
So you have to be practical,
like deeply practical.
But why not choose positivity?
Why not choose optimism?
It's why I have such unique
hard takes on COVID right?
I've been getting a ton
of emails about how much
my statement about if COVID
started 90 days earlier,
Kobe Bryant would be alive.
That really fucking hit
people, cause the Kobe thing
hit people and they know
I'm telling the truth.
That's the truth.
If COVID was a hundred days earlier,
Kobe Bryant would be
alive and most likely live
for another 60 years.
If you look at the traffic
accident data around the world,
every day, they are in traffic accidents
and you layer that to what's
happened over the last 60 days
as the world's been shut down.
You can start debating if
more lives have been saved.
Now that's the macro.
That doesn't make the person
that lost their grandmother
because a COVID feel any better,
but what that person doesn't
know, is they might've been
the person in the car that got hit.
Like life's complicated.
So nobody's right.
Yeah, it's all perspective.
So nobody's right, so why not
choose happy and optimism?
Why not choose it?
Like why not choose it?
Why not fight to learn how to choose it?
- I love that.
Thank you so much.
- I got you my guy.
Keep pushing.
- I will.
- I believe you.
So you soon.
- Se you.
- Let's keep it going.
- Hi.
- Hi Daniel, how are you?
- I'm losing my mind right now.
- Why?
- Cause at the fact of
talking to you, but am okay.
- I love your hair.
- Thank you.
So I guess what I kind of
wanted to talk to you about
was something that I haven't
heard talked about much
on here.
So I suffered from kidney
failure, I'm currently
on dialysis, right now
it's three days a week,
trying to work on doing it
at home, so that I can have
more time to do other things.
But my problem is, I have this drive
to do things, I guess.
I'm super creative, I like to
do art, I like to make videos,
I like to do pictures.
I'm all over the place, I guess.
And that's everybody,
- Danielle, that's good.
- Yeah.
- Do you know that, or do
people tell you that's not good?
- Yeah, everybody basically
makes me feel like
I need to pick something,
so that I can start
making money, because I have three kids,
and I'm not really financially successful.
I'm on disability right
now, so that's kind of
where I get my money, but
- Let's take out, COVID,
disability right out.
Are you happy?
Like this is a very
interesting question, right?
Let me explain.
Cause it's heavy, it's
a heavy question, right?
Because, because there's
a balance between,
you got to provide, but in
that sense, you're creative.
You've got a health
situation that's not going to
allow you to go ham 15
fucking hours a day,
seven days a week, cause then
that's not going to work out.
So I think this gets into, practical.
This goes back to the last question.
There's a level of practicality.
I think there's a 50 50 game for you.
And what I mean by that is,
I've been really excited
about this new idea I have
around strategic jobs.
So I think when I look at
you, I'm like, Oh, okay,
you just need a fucking
Epic job and we need to put
all our energy together
to find you that epic job,
and that really is fun enough because
it's created by nature, pays
some sort of foundational bills
for the plus three, right?
- Yeah.
- And still gives you the
ability, cause it's a nine to five
to when you're feeling
up to it, to do stuff
at nine to 11:00 PM, whether it's drawing
or coloring or graphics or music.
I think the biggest thing you have to put
all your energy towards,
and honestly I'm super happy
to help you, is to find the core.
Where do you live?
- In Portland, Oregon.
But we've been trying to move, we've been
in this house for five years.
We live in a super small
house, like it's barely
850 square feet maybe,
but two bedroom, and so
I sleep with two of my kids every night,
two children, make it work.
But I haven't had a job like really ever,
mostly due to my health.
So when I go apply at
jobs and I try to get
jobs, places I don't have
really anything on my resume,
and people look down on me.
- Let's talk about it because, I have
a funny feeling this community
is about to help you.
Talk to me about what you do.
Well, I want, to
- What do you make?
- Well I can make anything.
I make pictures, I want to make videos,
I want to talk to people, I
enjoy talking with people.
- Are you capable of making
social media content?
- Yeah, I try. I have
super bad insecurities,
which I'm trying to get over.
I've watched you for
like the last five years,
so I'm on Ticktock, I'm on
Instagram, I'm on LinkedIn,
I'm on all that stuff.
I'm trying to talk to people
and put myself out there
even though it's super hard for me,
cause I get super bad
anxiety, but I'm trying,
- Because you value their opinions of you.
- Yeah, I guess.
I'm worried that people aren't going to,
because everywhere that
I've gone, I feel like
when I've tried to get
jobs, I've tried to apply
to VaynerMedia for
example, but I don't have
a good resume, and
- The good news is VaynerMedia, is not
a resume game, VaynerMedia
is just a volume game.
We get so many applications,
but when you apply
for VaynerMedia, did you
apply for being a designer?
I have followed you for
five years, I've literally
applied for like, I
don't know how many jobs,
I've emailed you.
- Dustin, do me a favor,
connect here and let's get
Andy and D rock and the
team to talk to her and see,
let's let her make some
shit and let's see if
she's good or bad.
And here's the good
news on that, if you're
quote on quote bad to make you feel safe,
we're not going to be
like, "Oh you're bad,
" see yah Portland girl".
We're going to be like, "Hey, hey, this is
"what you want to work on."
Because I can tell you right now, there's
a thousand people right
now, that are probably
DM-ing your, is your Instagram down here?
Yeah, I have like 200 something followers.
I don't keep track cause
you know what they say,
don't focus on numbers.
So I try not to do that.
- Good for you, that
definitely is a very good idea.
On the flip side, having
a community is good,
however, that plays out.
let's just see, hold on.
- Yeah.
It's my anxiety always
gets the best of me,
and then I talked to like
professional business people
and then they don't take
me seriously because
I don't have like the credits or,
- Did you make this?
- I recolored that, off of spark post.
So I have the full Adobe creative cloud,
so I like to play on it and
mess around with it all the time
that I actually just recolored.
But everything else on
my Instagram I made,
I drew, I made everything else.
- This?
- I drew that.
- Okay, I can save you a lot
of time, you're good enough.
We're in a very interesting time.
I was only working with
people that, came to New York
and sat outside my office.
You've seen the blog,
you know how we like it.
I like fucking the
whole rat pack together,
like I love that shit.
Obviously the world's
different now and there's
opportunity and we've
started talking about
doing stuff with freelancers
at scale around the world.
Two things.
One, I'm going to have Tyler and Dustin's
listening right now.
I'm going have Tyler and Andy talk to you
about things that you
can do for VaynerMedia
are 1:37 PM or pure well, right?
Number two, I'm telling you right now,
on that single piece of content,
I'm completely convinced,
that people are DM-ing
you right now on your
account and telling you
that they'll pay you 500 bucks for a post
200 bucks for posts, 50 bucks for a post.
Like I genuinely believe
that you will have
real business in your Instagram right now
because so many people that
follow me are business people.
You're up to 348 so you're moving up,
are business people.
So you made you made this too, this video
that I'm watching right now.
- Yeah, that's a video
of my daughter, yeah.
- This you?
- Yeah, I made that.
- Right, let me give you
a huge piece of advice.
- Okay.
- You need to post things like
the two things I showed you.
You made this too?
- Yeah.
- Okay, listen to me.
You need to make
This?
- Yeah, I made that.
- Right, listen to me.
You need to post three
times a day, things like
the last four things I've showed you.
I'm completely convinced,
that there's things
that we can do together.
I think we could do some stuff,
but I'm telling you right now,
even way more interesting,
I'm completely convinced you're at 446
you're going up fast right now because
what's happening is,
there's a lot of people
in my community who have
ideas but they don't know
how to make.
So you're a blessing to them.
They're great business
people, probably better
business people than you,
you're a better artist
than them, and I have
a very funny feeling.
- I'm not good at the business
side of things at all.
- Alright, so let me help you then.
So the people that are
DM-ing you right now,
and I'm sure there's a
bunch, that are asking you
to make them a piece of content and you'll
get on a zoom with them
or call, like don't do
any content for less, $150 a post, right?
Like just see what that,
see what that feels like.
Like you only need four
or five customers, so like
to me your content creation
is good enough for sure.
Because I see a lot of
it, for sure to help a ton
of small businesses and I
just really genuinely think
that this is the moment that
where your new world changes.
- Wow.
Well, my mind is blown, so yeah.
I've been super hesitant
cause I try and put
my work out there but I never get like
very many reactions or responses.
- Cause you have a small base.
I didn't get a lot of reactions
either, but I kept posting
wine library TV more and more.
I kept putting out tweets more and more
and then that eventually helped
me build your base, right?
Your base is now doubled
because of the serendipity
of this moment, in five minutes.
That's how life works.
Somebody else is going to
repost something from you
and it's going to be 10
times bigger than that.
You're just good enough.
- Okay, It's hard for
me to admit that I guess
to myself, but it's like I also don't want
people to feel like I
just want like their money
cause they don't want to do that.
And I also want, like, I like what you do.
- But listen, but you need money.
- Yeah.
- Listen, every one of
those posts that I just saw
is worth $150.
Every one.
And if you, God forbid God willing,
God forbid as a slang term for
God-willing get six people,
just six people here right
now saying I want one
it's $1,000.
- Yeah.
It's like I want to do like
I like what you talked about
and leaving a legacy and it's like
I don't so much care,
- You can't leave a legacy
if you're out of business.
- Right.
- Like right?
Like do you know much easier,
it's going to be for you
to leave a legacy, if you're making
$4,000 a month, because
you're doing 30 of those posts
for people and now your family can move
and you can breathe a little
bit, which all of a sudden
is going to help your brain,
which is then going to
help your kidney.
Like you're going be
able to leave a legacy.
You can't do that if you're
not in a stable spot.
- Yeah, I've just felt
stuck for like so long.
- I get it.
- And I'm like, I don't know what to do.
- Good news, I think I understand
That's why I'm here right now.
I'm going to unfucking stuck you.
I'm giving you the blueprint,
I'm giving you the audience
and I'm telling you what to do.
If I didn't tell you the one-fifty part,
we would have hung up
and then you would have
all these things and you
would have been crippled
because it's not what you do.
It's no different than if you asked me
to put together a clock right now.
I'm not fucking handy out here.
If you're like, Gary, hang those curtains,
I'm like (mumbles), no different than you
not knowing to ask for 150.
You know?
- it's hard for me to
ask for money I guess,
`cause it makes me feel bad.
And then I don't come
from money, I don't know
- No, no let's stay here.
This is the reason I'm
staying here with you
is because you're helping
a lot of people right now.
There's a lot of people like you.
Let's play a different game.
Money doesn't have to
be bad, let me say this.
When you ask somebody for
$150 right, for that thing,
they don't have to say yes
and when they say fuck you,
$5, you don't have to say yes.
- Okay.
- You do understand that
the content, when you
talk to somebody for,
First of all, it's not just two seconds.
You have to talk to these
people for 10 minutes
so they can tell you what they want.
You're going to have to go onto their page
and figure out their business.
You're putting your talents to work.
- Yeah, I've made things
for people like for free,
because I know you say do
a bunch of stuff for free.
So I've made like logos and
tried to do things like that
for people for free.
- And free is great
when you can afford it,
but right now I don't
like the feeling I have.
I don't want you to do that.
I want you to go through a path of $150.
Listen, I can put $150,000
to give one speech, right?
- I would loose my mind.
- And guess what?
I lose my mind.
And at first, and there's
been times where I'm like,
man, that's insane, that's
more money than I made
in the first four years of my career.
But the reality is,
I've learned it because
this is how it works.
That's because the venue and the promoters
make that money back in
(mumbles) sum, because
I've worked my face off for my whole life
to have an audience that converts
when I speak on stage.
People like athletes make too much.
No, they don't.
They've worked super
hard and people watch it,
and then brands pay
for it and tickets sell
because of it.
They're making too little.
They are making too little.
And that's how I feel about you right now.
Like you've worked your
whole life to be creative.
You are naturally creative.
Even your physical appearance
is wildly creative.
You are creative.
- Thank you.
I don't want to be like super rich.
That's not my goal or anything.
- Don't be rich.
- But it's like I want
to have enough money
to be taking care of, and
to take care of my kids.
- Listen to me, humility is a superpower.
However, humility to a
fault where it hurts you
and the people that you love is a problem.
- Yeah.
- And thank God, I mean very honestly,
we've done this a lot.
A lot of times people aren't good enough.
Like a lot of times I
look at their accounts,
I'm like, ah, all right Cameron.
All right.
Dustin, lets go to the next
It's a bad spot because you
know that it's not worth it.
But I'd rather, but
you have enough in you.
I can see it.
- I'm trying to throw myself into like
what I'm doing and I've self
taught myself everything
I have, like I said, I have the
whole Adobe creative cloud.
- Put up coach, Jade
fitness studio says $150
there are people in my area charging
$3,500 for a post.
- That's just crazy to me, I don't know.
I would feel bad, I don't
know why it makes me feel bad.
- Because you weren't secure, because
you don't value yourself enough.
- Yeah, that's very true.
- No shit, but you know what?
You know the process to starting to feel
better about yourself,
is to start doing this.
So cute.
Start doing this and feeling that
that person paid you $150,
you delivered something.
They write you an email and
says, this is incredible,
can you do three more?
All of a sudden you go
from this to, you know?
- Yeah.
- Ironically, the thing
you need is to charge money
and get that positive
feedback to build you back up.
You're just in a vicious circle.
Yeah, I've been in kind
of like a up and down
depression for like the last five years
and then my health kind of shot me down
when I started having to do dialysis.
- Of course, it's a vicious cycle.
The brain is the operating system.
Look, at what Roberto Blake just said,
and Roberto, Roberto has done a great job
building himself up and
like, this is a big deal.
- I've talked to him
a few times on Twitter
as well as like, I've
talked to Dustin and Zane
a few times on Twitter too.
And I try and interact with
everybody as much as I can.
- You are doing a great job.
You've got the talent, you're interacting
now we just have to push you over the top
to get comfortable for asking
for money and delivering.
But I'm telling you right now, take it
from the horse's mouth.
You have enough in you.
Too many people that
are creative were taught
by their parents and their circumstance
that money is bad.
- I'm not really one of
those people who like
have my parents, I don't know.
Not to get into anything, but like I come
from a bad childhood and
so I took me and my fiance
here with our kids and we
don't have nobody else.
- Well, good news.
You don't fucking need anybody else.
I mean like those family
photos are sweet as fuck.
- Thank you.
- You have way more than most people.
There are plenty of people
who do not have fiance
or the three kids.
- Oh yeah, I know.
I'm incredibly thankful even to have them.
- So that's it.
- That's why I want to show my kids,
like I want to show them that like
- Mom can be successful,
I can do something.
But you need to get over yourself
and your insecurities about
charging money for your art.
Like what do you think I'm
spending my time doing here?
I'm not here for my health.
I'm here because you represent
hundreds of thousands
of people that will watch this video
over the next 10 years.
People don't think about content properly.
We're having this moment right
now with tens of thousands
of people watching on
live, then it's going to go
on Instagram and that's
going to get its views.
Then it's going to go on
YouTube and it's going to get
those views but somebody's
going to watch this video
in 13 years on YouTube or
Twitch or Schmidt, coicher.
Whatever ends up happening,
and this single video
is going to change your life.
And if you want to be
good to other people,
it's your responsibility now to execute
on this moment so that
when they look you up,
they can see that you've flourished.
- And I've been trying
to practice with like,
I know you say document over create,
and I know I'm highly creative, so I get
stuck in that and I'm like,
- No, no, no, no.
I say document over creating
for people that can't create.
You my dear, can create.
You understand?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You can fucking create.
- I just want to do so many
things, and I feel like
it's like, and I learn best by doing
- You know how you do so many things?
- How?
- By doing one thing and
building on top of it.
Do me a huge favor.
Start a business now, right this second.
You're going to hang up
and you're going to have
an ungodly amount of DMS,
and go by one by one,
one by one, right?
So wait a minute, did we have
the wrong Instagram before?
I see some complete,
No, no, we got the right one.
That's right, we got it.
Everybody, that's the
Instagram, instagram.com/ that
if you want to share it
in your Twitter or Twitch
or YouTube right now to make it linkable,
let's all rally and drive it.
By the way, I don't know if you know this,
but check this out. You're at 950.
- Oh my God, that's crazy.
- Listen to me better than
that, better than that,
you've got real DMS and I'm promising you,
Let me guess here, you
probably have 45 DMS right now
that say $150.
They're literally ready to pay you.
You probably probably
probably, made five to $10,000
just right now.
- Okay, that's crazy.
What you need to do is
you need to not do any
for less than 150, you
have to promise me this.
- Okay.
- And you have to say
yes, do you have a PayPal?
- Yeah.
- Great.
You know you're on your way kid.
- Yeah, I turned 29 on
the 16th this month.
So I've been having super
bad anxiety cause I'm like,
I'm getting old.
- Let me say it one more
time, you're on your way kid.
I worked in a liquor store when I was 29.
- Yeah
I know.
Well thank you so much.
I appreciate you talking with me.
- You're going to be very
busy from next month.
- Well I'm very happy cause I've been,
I've had so much time
on my hands, I'm like,
I don't know what to make
or what to create, so
- You take these DMS, you see
who's offering the most money
because there's some people that might say
500 bucks or 800 bucks.
You get on zoom with
them or Google hangout,
you talk to them what
they want for 15 minutes,
30 minute consultation,
you hang up, you make it,
you have them PayPal, you
20 to 50% of the money.
This is going to be hard
for you, you tell them
you need a deposit, this is
going to be hard for you.
You're just scared to ask for
money, let alone a deposit.
But you need to stick with
me here and you need to
re-watch this video
over and over in a week.
If you are not doing it, you
have to ask for a deposit,
You have to ask for a deposit.
- Okay, I'm ready to do it.
I've been trying, I've been offering to,
I've been trying to start my
business, but I wasn't sure.
Everyone's like, Oh you
should do photography
cause you're so good at
photography, which I enjoy it
and I like it
- And you are, I see it.
Right now you can't do that.
So you need to wait to do that.
You'll do that later
and by then you'll learn
how to charge, but
right now, listen to me,
right now you have literally
$5,000 sitting in your inbox.
I mean, I'm going to assume
based on what I'm hearing,
that's a big fucking deal.
- Yeah, we live paycheck to paycheck, so
- Literally, literally this
is your opportunity to not,
because what's amazing,
is that three or four
of those people are probably
going to do more than
one time with you because
you're going to be
their person.
- Yeah, okay.
It's just hard.
Now as far as like one
of my hang ups on like
creating a business is like
I get hung up on a name
and you say like not to do that,
because they don't mean anything.
It doesn't mean anything.
McDonald's sounds like an
Irish pub, not a fucking,
the greatest chain
restaurant in the history of
capitalist America.
- Yeah, but I hate my first
name, I've never liked
my name Danielle, I've never liked it.
So I've been calling
my business or decided
to call my business like
Chris being creative,
or something else creative
- You know who else hated their name?
- Who?
- Prince!
- Yeah.
- So change your fucking name.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- What do you mean you don't know?
- I mean, I don't know.
Most people just call me something else.
- What do most people call you?
- Most people, call me Dee.
- So change your fucking name to Dee!
- Okay.
- Dee designs, D-E-E.
There you go, D-E-E
Just like GaryVee.
D-E-E designs
There you go, that's your company's name.
Good?
- Okay, good.
- What else?
- So as far as back onto the whole like
documenting thing, just
because I also do get
messages from people from
like a health standpoint
and people wanting to talk to me about
what I'm going through because I'm young
and dealing with dialysis.
I go in my dialysis center AND
- Hey Dustin, real quick.
I apologize, I know this is important.
Can you check if D-E-E is available on
Instagram because then we'll help her
- I shouldn't have said that, cause now
someone is going to steal it.
- Somebody's going to steal it in here,
that's going to transfer.
Nobody's steal it so we
can transfer it to her
if it's available.
Go ahead D-E-E
So go ahead, people want to talk to you?
- So it's like, I go
into my dialysis center
and everybody in there
is way older than I am.
I'm the youngest person in there.
And so lots of people always want to
ask me questions or what's wrong with me.
- Of course, why are you here?
- Yeah, and things like that.
And I've thought about documenting
just to like talk to people cause
I do enjoy talking to people and trying to
help where I can, but it's like I don't,
but as far as documenting,
I want to like try
to document my life because I like,
I love watching everyone
on YouTube who does that.
But I don't want to put
my kids in everything,
- So don't.
- I don't put my kids in anything.
- But they are always with me
Then go outside, go fucking
outside, or send them out.
You got your man, let him
hold him down for 13 seconds
while you make a clip.
Listen to me, excuses aren't valuable.
- Yeah, I know.
I just need to make and
do I know and I'm trying,
I need to get over my
- Insecurity.
- Insecurities
- Let me tell you how you can
get over your insecurities
by charging all these people, $150 or more
for design and feeling that affirmation of
creating success for you and your family.
I promise you it will work.
It's where I found my affirmation.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Yeah, and that's what
I've been searching for.
It's like I just want
to have like a purpose.
- This.
I put it on a fucking
silver platter for you.
If you don't eat it, I'm
going to fly to Portland
and punch you in the face.
Even he thought that was
funny and that's your man.
- That's my husband.
- I'm shocked.
You know what I mean?
Don't miss this spot.
What's your husband's name?
- Ben.
- Ben, get in here.
- Hey Gary?
- Sup brother.
It's good to see you.
- How is the going?
- Really well.
Ben, don't don't miss this moment.
It's a real moment.
Like there's literally
$7,000 in her direct messages
right now.
- oh, I'll push her.
- I believe you, but support her, because
she's obviously got all
the other variables.
So this is not about
pushing, this is about
balancing through this, right?
Not like, "Hey baby, you
can do it, or hey baby,
you got to finish the other one".
This is more like, "hey, at
your own pace, you got this.
"If it takes you four
months to get through
"all this, that'll be fine too".
That's support versus push.
Do you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, I hear you.
- She needs that.
- I'm here for her.
- I know, bro.
- I'll support you, babe.
- I love you guys.
Have a great day.
- We love you too.
Thank you so much Gary.
- You're welcome.
See ya.
Tea with GaryVee Dustin
- The best show on the earth.
- It's a different fucking thing.
I'm going to really have to figure out
how to do it when things
go back to normal.
- Yeah, I've been thinking about that too.
I mean we could pretty
much do the same thing,
like just ask GaryVee style, but then
just have a good camera
for you in your office.
- This is just different.
I don't know.
Awesome.
Thank you brother.
Before I get out of
here, today is the single
most exciting day in Winetext's history.
Talk transition from that
last one, but I need to
do it because it's going
to be the greatest.
Please, please, please
listen to me carefully.
If you're on Winetext, you
already know where I'm going
because we've been promoting it on email
and on text like crazy because it's true.
Today's Winetext is, in my honest opinion,
and I think you guys know
me, the single best deal
that we've ever put out,
it's a 50, $60 wine.
I think it's like $62 on
wine.com and it's going to be
under $20 a bottle.
It's from Napa, It's so ridiculous that
I can't even,
- We lost Gary one second.
- Like, it's so ridiculous that I left,
like it's so ridiculous that I left.
By the way, I saw somebody
say violence isn't the answer,
but I'm not flying to
Portland punching anybody
and I'm not punching a man in the face,
let alone a woman.
Relax, we're having fun.
Winetext, it is going to be crazy today,
and if you buy wine, please,
if you buy wine at all,
please sign up for Winetext
right now and get ready
cause in two hours it goes
off, the greatest deal
of all time.
Like knowing that it's $19 and change
and knowing a lot of
you buy 10 and $12 wines
and get a dollar value,
but this is $19 and change
and it's $70 value, it's crazy.
And there's a lot of you on
Winetexts, please do me a favor.
This would mean a lot to me actually.
If you can text one person,
everybody, just one person,
text one person, the
winetext.com URL right now
and say they should sign up.
If you've got a real
wine friend in your life,
a boss, a friend, just
if you got a wine homey,
if every single, yes,
yesterday's wine tax was legit.
K Nixon, today's wine tax takes
a shit on yesterday's offer.
Like a shit.
That's how insane this is.
So if you have wine friends,
it would mean the world to me,
if you can text winetext.com
to them and say,
"Hey, today's offers crazy
sign up before noon Eastern"
so, it'd mean a lot to me.
Thank you so much.
Talk to you soon.
I'll see you tomorrow.
And if you're not signed
up for the podcast,
in case tea with GaryVee doesn't continue,
post COVID, the podcast I
think is the real alternative.
That morning boost so
many workout with it,
so many walk the dog with
it, that morning boost
I think is right there with the podcast.
So please check it out.
I realize a lot of you
that watch Tea with GaryVee
aren't signed up for my podcast.
That makes me sad.
Here's what you're missing out on.
- No, you've like helped me so much.
- Thank you bro.
- And like, navigating
like it's all mindset.
- Yeah, preach it.
- like when I entered college
I had such a bad mindset
because I was like, I don't
really want to be here,
I just want to work.
But like listening to
the podcast everyday,
having like positivity of my years,
it was really just like helped me along.
- Gary, if mindset has
been skewed, how can you
bring it back?
And I answered with, by
surrounding yourself with people
who have the mindset you aspire to.
Mold and I mean mold your
mindset by what you consume
and with whom you consume.
If you think you're like the
shit, you're like the shit.
Keep listening to more of my content.
You need fucking positivity
coming through your ears
when fucking all that negativity
is coming in your head.
Put your fucking headphones
in and listen to positivity.
If6 you can't move out
yet, put shit in your ears.
You walk in, put the fucking headphones on
in your house, close your
door and fucking listen.
You can listen while you're
driving, you can listen,
while you're traveling,
you can listen while
you're working out, you can
while you're walking the dog.
Like find your shit.
Like don't listen to the
fucking people that shit on you.
Like get in your own head.
Put positivity around you.
Drop loser friends like, that negativity
that you're hearing,
you've got to get that
the fuck out of Your life
You need to put your fucking ear pods in
and listen to positivity 24 seven
to get yo through that shit.
You understand?
When your surroundings
are shit, your insides
got to be positive.
The fact you're even here means
you're fucking half way home.
(music playing)